MATHIS HERE MATHIS HERE
AGUIAR-CURRY FLORA LINE HERE
GALLAGHER HERE GALLAGHER HERE
GRAY IRWIN THERE AND I'M HERE
JONES SAWYER HERE COUNSELING
HERE IN THE GAME THERE HAVE
SALAS ROSA SOUNDS PRESIDENT
CLEARLY I WOULD HAVE THOUGHT
OF IT WAS LIKE TO PRESENT
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
FIVE CREEK AGRICULTURAL
BAKER COUNCIL THIS SOUTH PART
DIFFERENT PART OF COMPAQ BORN
DON'T FIT I PRESENTED EARLIER
IN THE YEAR GIFTS THAT CAN HOLD
UP VILLAGE COUNCIL RIGHT THIS
OPPORTUNITY FARMERS VEHICLE
-- CITY'S COUNCIL WOULD HAVE
REPRESENTATIVE FROM REGULATORY
STATE FINDS TO BE ABLE TO BRING
CONFLICTS AND PROBLEMS THAT
THEY HAVE FOLLOWING REGULATION
-- IF THE PARTICULAR --
INTERESTED CAN BE SURE
THAT WE'RE PROTECTING SMALL
FARMS ARE SLOWLY COMING THE
STATE KOREA MISS PROVIDES
A PLACE LIKE THAT THEIR
CONCERNS HAVE I HAVE RAISED
THEM IT'S OPEN PUBLIC
PROCESS I CAN'T FEEL HAPPY
REGULATORY AGENCIES RESPOND
SO PLEASE TAKE A SECOND LOOK
AT SOME I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR THANK YOU -- REPUBLICAN
SUPPORT PUBLIC COMMENT IS
FOR CA NONPUBLIC COMMON IN
OPPOSITION THE BILL GOT A
MOTION AND A SECOND SEEN OUR
COMMENT MEMBERS YOU'RE TELLING
SECRETARY CULTURAL THE MOTION
ASSESSMENT AMENDMENTS BEACON
COLONEL CAMBIADO FIVE ZERO
AYE MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE AND
YEAR CURRY LARA -- FLORA HIGH
GALLAGHER GALLAGHER AYE GRAY
AYE GRAY AYE IRWIN AYE AND
WHEN I JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE AND THAT MEANS I'D
LET ME AYE SALAS AYE SOUND
FUN IT'S BILLS AL-ASSAD'S
LARA FIND SENSATIONALIST OUT ON
THERE ARE LIKE THREE
NCROWD OUT THERE
GOD IF YOU CARRY OUT OF US
LONG LIFE GOOD HOMES ON IT
AVAILABILITY VICTORIES